Hi, I'm Boris, an engineer
working in
Chrome developer relations.
Today, I'd like to show you
how to use the remote
debugging feature in Chrome
for Android Beta.
Before you get started, make
sure you've installed the
Android SDK, which includes
the Android
Debug Bridge utility.
Once ADB is installed,
run the following
command in your terminal.
Next, enable remote debugging in
Chrome for Android by going
to Settings, Developer Tools,
and enabling the option.
Now, you'll be able to view all
open tabs in Chrome for
Android by accessing local
host on port 9222 in your
desktop browser.
Clicking a link in your desktop
browser opens the
Chrome developer tools
for that tab.
Here, you can see the Chrome
developer tools inspecting
your mobile browser.
As you'd expect, hovering over
an element in the inspector
highlights it in the browser.
You can manipulate the page
using the same Chrome
developer tools you're
used to.
Here, I've hidden an element
by setting it's CSS display
property to none.
You can also run scripts
in-line.
Here, I've created an alert
in the inspected page.
Remote debugging gives you
access to these, and many
other, powerful dev tools
features, such as live
editing, HTML, CSS, and
Javascript, breakpoints, and
code beautification.
For more information about
remote debugging in Chrome for
Android Beta, visit
code.google.com/chrome/mobile.